ん
th
うぜ以降は時間年だよ桜を放って ok
行ってきますありがとう今日のいや
2カ月間
お世話になりましたん
沖縄でさいあじゃあこの手前の氷はいあるだろ
ございましたありがとうございます
おおこれかとしポケモン東京でにだけそうだったんですけどもうその咳もほぼ
コンプリートね俺含めてねポケモンといえば後に
ミュウツーと沖縄にしか出ない325
そして今日波戸氏は今日こそはと氏はようやく波戸氏は静岡に帰りますマジでそのまま
足族帰ろうと思ったんですけども
バーカやろ
たいせつな忘れものてしまった325ポケモンゴーでさんにごって実は日本だと沖縄と
か鹿児島のあの
阿南とかあの結構赤道近くの地域にしか出ないらしくて
これはなんとしても本当にも何としてでも僕3人を含めた32個だけを捕まえたいん
ですよ
サニー号を取っても捕まえたいんでちょっと東京頑張った僕にご褒美
てわけでもないんですけどサニー号機を捕まえて静岡に帰りたいと思ってるんで
今日はただ今あなたの80万円なんとしてでもなんと酢でもメントスでの今日はなく
なって罰を受け恥ずかしいよねちょっとめっちゃパッカーみられて見れなきゃ
難しいカメラに向かってしゃべってる変だよまあ簡単に言うと
日帰りで俺様松家静岡に帰ろうと思います皆になる
でコストで一人で沖縄の日にを取って行きの便の帰りの便もとってやって完璧に静岡に
帰れる状態になっているので沖縄にほんの少ししかいられない
多分短時間ぐらいですけど退会できないんですけど初めて国内点取るんですよ
沖縄でサニー号を捕まえるだけの被告なんで私325を捕まえるのにどれくらいの時間
がかかるのかコンプ
検証していこうと思いますいやービビるぜそれで捕まらなかったら俺マジで終わりだぜ
ま市矢部迷子になるそのホッケーつもあきらめかけてて沖縄行く時がではずだと思った
んですけど俺はそれでもつけていきます愛ちゃんっ
[音楽]
えええええええ
俺のフレンドだぜ
yeah
k 実などにぐんぐん
中学旅行か連日だけど数学力講座から人がいましたねそれも同じ飛行機ではないジョブ
かな
網中の宣伝でね
ああああああ
ni
騒ぎになってもうたのっ
私をやっつけるのではーいじゃあ before マン未来ください
遊ぶカバーもありますけどこれはちょっと痛いと言うけど沖縄つきました
製剤にバレてしまったんですけどまぁ許容範囲んでしょまたここで廃材探偵た後6日に
入ってくれるはずなんですけど
行っちゃう本当に一時コツコツ買いたい食べてたときっちゃ ko
アルファでラベルああ
助六さんじゃないですかトゥデイ
吐き63じゃない負担ゼロカーんです
z ご飯も知らないジャスっていうんですよあっ広い箇所も違ってるんですか
化粧もし動いてるだけ打つ takeshi takeshi ですよ餌だけ10桁
買うんですけど黒ストンって14時30分
アトリエ1時間もですあたり時間を消す犬ってか熱い船
ツイン湘南ことでつい
どうぞみな女は
ん
もっといただったなぁ
book 今日まで東京にいて
教師像が買えると思っているんですよいろいろ a
ただ砂利のこそ方もあるという夏の思い出なんでもねぇと思ってん
元の図ほんとなったですよねサニー号を守ってもらっていっ
うわぁ行き損ですよそれはどこかで総スカン
本能アルマシーなんともないです安保のモノレールあるっ
立った
car
ぶっぱ
お尻アウト15日からねそれでもね15ニングってくれたパットとれざるですよねなん
とかなんと公園の
フジだけ運動公園
いければ僕がう
一番好きなポケモンなんだと思いますよ
ずいるか疑問の中であのーいいなんかなんですかね
じゃあ多分好きな多分なんですよ
[音楽]
ブーバー扱い行くぞ
可愛くない voodoo
ですけど春漁は4月号館笑顔がいいポケモンなんて単なる5分
だから動画で行
二辛さを得がるするっていう気持ちでやってみてくださいね
そういうことでありますなかなか出てこですねなかなか出てこない
もうちょっとっ
あれだなプレッシャー管理者ばいいですね取れるって言ったからにはちょっと
ねだり方ぜひ曲がるとすると確かにたーーーー
ないかなぁ
ブーブー言っにッッッま
どうにか埼玉じゃんこれ
て坊
でそれが続2325でしょ大
モンスターボールの回転って言っ
入っん
さーさーさーどがー
p ああああ
いいいい
me
あっはっ
2分
札うっ
実5
タマ姉税
さっき行きません325捕まえましたアーチャーん
帰ります同じよっけどそれだそれはん
ん
2ヶ月ぶりの静岡です
ています
[音楽]
すごいアクセルぞ
b
はずねぇ
アミーゴ